T
ONE NARROW ISSUE, AND THEN THE
COURT OF APPEALS WOULD BE
DEALING WITH THE BROADER SET OF
ISSUES.
>> RENATO, I WANT TO GET YOUR
THOUGHTS ON THE CASE IN FULTON
COUNTY, GEORGIA, BECAUSE THE
D.A. THERE, FAWNY WILLIS, SAYS
HER INVESTIGATION IS GOING TO GO
QUIET UNTIL AT LEAST AFTER THE
MIDTERM ELECTIONS TO AVOID ANY
APPEARANCE OF TRYING TO
INTERFERE OR INFLUENCE THE
ELECTION.
I WONDER IF YOU THINK THAT IS
THE RIGHT MOVE, AND OUT OF THE
DOZENS OF PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN
TOLD THEY MIGHT BE TARGETS, WHO
DO YOU THINK MIGHT ACTUALLY BE
INDICTED?
>> SO I DO THINK THAT'S THE
RIGHT MOVE BECAUSE UNLESS
THERE'S REASON TO BELIEVE
SOMEONE'S GOING TO FLEE OR
THERE'S A STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS
ISSUE, I DON'T SEE ANY REASON
WHY A PROSECUTOR SHOULD INDICT
SHORTLY BEFORE AN ELECTION,
WHICH IS GOING TO ADD TO
CONCERNS AND SPECULATION THAT
THIS WAS SOMEHOW POLITICALLY
MOTIVATED.
I THINK THAT WAS THE RIGHT MOVE.
I REALLY BELIEVE THE DA IS GOING
TO INDICT THE FORMER PRESIDENT
AND A NUMBER OF HIS TOP AIDES.
I THINK SHE'S GOING TONY DIET,
FOR EXAMPLE, RUDY GIULIANI.
SO I HAVE TO SAY THAT ALL SIGNS
HAVE POINTED TO HER TAKING A
VERY AGGRESSIVE APPROACH HERE.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN HE'LL BE
CONVICTED.
I THINK SHE'S GOT A DIFFICULT
CASE AND A LOT OF WORK TO BE
DONE ON HER END, BUT
NONETHELESS, I THINK IT
DEFINITELY HAS TO BE A CONCERN
FOR THE FORMER PRESIDENT,
BECAUSE AT THE SAME TIME AS WE
SPOKE ABOUT A MOMENT AGO, HE'S
DEALING WITH AN EVEN BIGGER
THREAT FROM THE UNITED STATES
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE.
>> RIGHT.
WE'RE ANTICIPATING